it was on July 2nd 1776 that the
Continental Congress voted to separate
the 13 colonies from British rule yet
it's on July 4th that we celebrate
Independence Day why because it was on
that day that the Declaration of
Independence was adopted its audience
not just the citizens of the 13 states
but the world at large what the
Declaration refers to has decent respect
to the opinions of mankind it's on July
4th then that the revolutionary
principles spelled out in the
declaration first major public
appearance here for the first time in
history a nation was resting its
legitimacy on the demands of human
nature and natural equality and not on
the common blood language religion or
traditions that is why we celebrate
Independence Day on the 4th is the
principle set out in the Declaration
that define this new nation not as
Lincoln noted a mere change of masters
July 4th is a day to celebrate America's
birth it is also the day that Americans
gave birth to a set of ideas that
transform not only this country but
eventually the world do you think the
Declaration of Independence was written
just for the United States or for the
world at large let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI